- So, last time you were here,
I thought you said you were like,
"No, I'm done with Madea"
and I love that you brought her back.
I feel like we need her.
She makes me laugh.
(audience cheers)
- I tell you.
- She makes me so happy.
- I tell you what happened.
And that's exactly why I brought her back.
Looking at the pandemic,
looking at all the
social and civil unrest,
looking at all the madness
and looking at everything
that's happened in the country.
I'm like, "We need to laugh."
All of our smiles were covered up.
I'm like, "What do I have in my toolbox
that will make people laugh?"
And I open it up and
somebody says, "Hello."
- (Kelly) Hello!
- And here we are, so yeah, on Netflix,
I'm excited.
- I love it!
I know it makes me so happy,
and I love, this was a specific,
it's, you spoke about LGBTQ
community in this one.
I think it's cool.
It's a different message.
- (Tyler) Yeah.
- For this Madea, was that
really important to you?
- Yeah, I just, again
looking at the trauma
and the heartache and how
much everybody has to say
about other people and the
way they live their lives.
You get one life, life is short, right?
So I wanted to show a gay character
coming out to his family, a Black family.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- And they're embracing
him and showing him love.
- I was just gonna say, I loved that.
I loved that it actually did that.
- It's a great example.
- It wasn't like the
typical, like, oh, it's hard.
'Cause yes, it is hard, you know,
for people, I have friends
that it was hard for-
- (Tyler) Very hard for some, yeah.
- And some of their
family don't talk to them,
but some are, they embrace it.
They love you.
It's not a big deal.
And I think we don't hear
those stories enough.
- That's why it was so
important for me to show.
'Cause I do a lot of
work with Covenant House
who've over the years,
they have, you know,
a lot of kids are homeless
because they were put out
because they were LGBTQ plus.
And to see-
- Can you imagine that?
I mean we're both parents.
- It's horrible.
- What?
- I don't even know how.
Listen, I couldn't even imagine,
the love that I have for my child.
- (Kelly) Infinite.
- Infinite, you know?
And to think because of
the way they were born
you would really just discard them,
is shocking to me that people can do that.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I don't get that either.
- I think it's really cool
that you use a powerful message
in such a powerful way
because people love to laugh.
They love to, they're already
a part of this character,
they love the-
- Thank you babe, I appreciate.
I appreciate it so much.
I appreciate so much, I appreciate babe.
I've been around a long time.
- This is what I love too.
Wait, I love that you took Madea
and you made these posters.
I was dying.
- Oh listen.
- Wait, so here's some of the posters.
This is The Frown.
(she laughs)
Which is amazing.
- (Tyler) Yeah.
- (Kelly) Wait, this is Madeagerton.
- (Tyler) That's right, you said it right.
- (Kelly) Madeagerton.
- (Tyler) Madeagerton.
- (Tyler) Yeah.
- Oh my God, first of
all, wait, keep it up,
guy on the right is the
creepiest one of us.
Awesome, it's my favorite one.
It's so funny.
- Brendan O'Carroll, "Mrs. Brown."
He's huge in Europe, so.
- Oh my God, I know.
I love it, it's amazing.
- (Tyler) Yeah.
- It's so great.
And wait, this is awesome too.
Shout out to Adele, Ma-Dele 90.
- (Tyler) Ma-Dele, yeah.
- My favorite thing is you said 90.
'Cause she does.
- Right, she does.
So Adele did 30, that's
Madea's 90 year old album.
So, and her hit song is called "Hello."
- Hello?
- Hello.
- Hello, you should do a music video.
- Album, it's a whole album.
- It's like cover of all-
- That's great.